from day one of the Donald Trump with public
and tax guts.
I've been reminding the audience
and imploring and begging people to understand
how these corporate tax cuts will be used.
They will not be used to create jobs.
They will not be used in ways that will be
good for the economy at large or for the average
worker.
We knew from the beginning that these corporate
tax cuts, we're going to be used by big companies
to buy back company stock to drive up the
share price and they will be used for companies
that have plans of automating away jobs, offshoring
jobs, leaving the United States with the manufacturing
facilities.
The tax cut money will be used to accelerate
that companies hire when there's more demand
for their products.
If you give corporations and rich people tax
cuts that doesn't generate more demand for
their products.
And Walmart is a great example of this.
This is uh, uh, yet another one of these data
points, which I will tell you about momentarily
that confirms exactly every single one of
our predictions about how these tax cuts would
work.
A great example of this that we already knew
about from before the tax cuts was remember
that huge victory that Donald Trump and Mike
pence claimed before Trump was even Iraq inaugurated.
Trump claimed to have made a big deal to keep
a, uh, an air conditioning factory.
I believe it was carrier.
I'm going from memory here, carrier in Indiana.
Maybe it was Ohio, but I think it was Indiana.
And Trump said, we made a deal.
They are now going to stay because they believe
in the business environment that we will have
under the Trump administration or whatever.
It wasn't a deal.
Trump just gave them money.
That's not economic policy.
It's here.
Take some cash.
And ultimately, once we got past the propaganda
carrier, still decided to move jobs out of
the United States and still decided to continue
moving forward on the automation of many of
the jobs that they plan to automate.
For Awhile before Donald Trump handed them
some cash, we even heard from company executives
that they would be using some of that money
to continue moving in the direction of automating
more of their jobs.
That was before Donald Trump's tax cuts even
went in, uh, into effect.
Walmart has now announced that it will be
laying off 570 employees in North Carolina.
They're going to close their corporate office
near Charlotte's airport.
Walmart saved one point $6 billion in the
first three quarters of 2018 thanks to Donald
Trump's tax cuts according to the New York
Times.
And the bigger picture estimate is that Donald
Trump's corporate tax cut will save Walmart
about two point $2 billion per year.
This is why you can't fall for the headline
about bonuses that companies are paying because
of Trump's tax cuts or wage increases or whatever.
Trump and other right wingers made a huge
deal of Walmart paying some employees these
thousand dollar bonuses.
All thanks to Donald Trump's wise and incredibly
intelligent tax cuts.
Donald Trump would talk about it all the time.
Back in January of 2018 2018 he would retweet
stuff like this clip from his friend Maria
Bartiromo over at Fox business network in
January of 2018 claiming massive victory at
Walmart because of the tax cuts.
Take a look.
Trickle down tax reform.
Walmart, the country's largest private employer,
just announce major changes saying that it
will raise its US minimum wage to $11 an hour.
It will pay a one time bonus of up to $1,000
to hourly workers and it will expand maternity
and parental leave benefits.
President Trump spoke more about the positives
of tax reform during his cabinet meeting yesterday.
Wow.
$11 per hour and $1,000 bonuses, which by
the way, still doesn't take most of those
employees out of the federal poverty level
of income and then hours later after that
video, after that announcement, Walmart announced
it was going to close 63 Sam's club stores.
They were laying off thousands of people and
by the way, they all of a sudden had $20 billion
to do a stock buy back, which is really great
for their executives and it's really great
for their big shareholders.
This is how it works.
Okay?
This is not a bug.
This is a feature of how these tax cuts are
designed to work.
Qualcomm did the same thing.
They did a $10 billion stock buy back and
laid off 1500 people in California.
This is why it is correct for people like
Bernie Sanders and Andrew Yang and Elizabeth
Warren to be going after these companies that
pay no taxes or pay very little in taxes.
And then they lay people off and then they
automate jobs and then they do stock buy backs
and they are completely subsidized by the
government, which subsidizes their low wages
for their employees with various welfare programs.
And I want to be super clear here that I'm
being understood about what my view is.
Of course, companies are going to do this
if they are allowed to do it.
This isn't about anything other than restructuring
the regulatory environment and what these
companies are allowed to do and understanding
that in order to fix the problem we have in
this country of inequality and a system of
government justice of everything for the rich
and corporations and a different system for
what we might call the underclasses, uh, we
are going to need to seriously rethink more
than just should the wage be 11, 12 or $15
like that.
That's not going to solve the problem, okay?
We're not talking about taking these companies
out of business, okay?
They wouldn't be good for the economy, for
Amazon and carrier and whatever companies
you want to name to go out of business.
That's not what we're targeting.
That's not what Social Democrats won.
They employ people, they provide products
that people want and need.
What I am saying is that they can pay their
fair share period.
They can play by tighter rules, period.
And what you have to understand is that the
anti socialism movement on the right is a
red herring, bad faith movement, partially
because anything they don't like, they just
call socialism.
And we've talked about that before, but they
actually benefit from the closest things to
socialist policies that exist in the United
States.
The closest thing we have to socialism is
the way in which corporate America's costs
are socialized through welfare programs and
corporate welfare, but the profits are all,
there's, we talk about this with environmental
disasters, okay?
It's extremely common in the United States
that environmental disasters for fossil fuel
companies and energy companies, it's capitalism
for the profits to their corporations, to
the, uh, to the corporations, and then it's
socialism for the cleanup costs, for the damage
they do to the environment.
Okay, this has to stop.
We have said it before, and I'll say it again.
This is bigger than a $15 minimum wage.
This is bigger than family, a paid family
medical leave.
This has to be a bigger restructuring of our
relationships to work and the corporate corporate
regulatory environment.
You're not going to get it from Republicans.
You're not going to get it from centrist Democrats.
That's an important thing.
We talked yesterday on the show how Joe Biden
was caught caught.
He said behind closed doors to rich donors
in New York City.
Uh, but I, I'm going to be loyal to you.
I need you.
Nothing significantly is going to change for
you.
Centrist Democrats are not going to change
this.
They'll throw some crumbs while letting the
rich keep their big rich decadent cakes as
I said yesterday and they'll throw some cake
crumbs to the lower, lower middle and middle
class.
Something else is going to need to change
and most candidates, basically every Republican
and centrist Democrats don't even want to
admit that our problems are bigger than bringing
back some manufacturing jobs or increasing
the minimum wage to 15 bucks.
You're not dealing with the systemic issues.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show.
I will be taking your phone calls shortly.
I will also be dealing later on in the show
with a very interesting audience question
about isolationism versus non interventionism.
They are very different things and the political,
domestic, political and geopolitical implications
of one versus the other are drastically
different.
That's coming up a little bit later today.